on behalf of sinn fein i wish to extend
our condolences on the death of queen
elizabeth ii
whose sorrowful loss is felt deeply by
her family and by many people across our
society particularly those of unionist
and british tradition whom with great
pride and devotion whole queen elizabeth
and the royal family very dear
her life and legacy will be fondly
remembered by many people around the
world
i think everybody will agree that it was
a mammoth achievement to have marked 70
years of dedicated public service
to the british people when she
celebrated her platinum jubilee earlier
this year
today i wish to record the value and the
respect i place on the significant
contribution queen elizabeth made to the
advancement of peace and to
reconciliation between the different
traditions on our island and between
ireland and britain during the years of
the peace process
it is appropriate that this is
rightfully recognized in this chamber
today
for the last 70 years
she was there
opening parliament
appointing prime ministers
leading our nation in remembrance
awarding honours to the best of those
among us
and
even for some dictating how quickly we
at our christmas dinner so that we could
hear the queen in time
in an ever-changing world
in times of great national joy and
celebration
and in times of sorrow sadness and grief
she was the anchor
one we could look to for stability
continuity and comfort
and as we draw together today to pay our
tributes um to the late her majesty
queen elizabeth ii
i think we first remember that at the
heart of all of this
whilst the commonwealth and this country
have lost a monarch
and there is a family that are grieving
the loss of a mother a grandmother a
great grandmother a confidant and friend
and a matriarch and it is to them that i
turn my thoughts first today in offering
them my condolences and those of my
colleagues
when we reflect on monarchy of course we
acknowledge that there are a range of
views on the institutions
it is one of immense privilege however
not everyone who is subject to such
immense privilege gives so much in
return
and i think it is a remarkable
achievement not just to have served and
to have served on the throne as the
queen did for such a long period but to
have done so with such unswerving
dedication to judy right to her final
hours to have continued in the work to
which she was called i believe is a
remarkable legacy that she leaves behind